A
POWERPOINT.
SO CAN WE START THE
PRESENTATION?
>> YEAH!
SO WE PREPARED A PRESENTATION ON
WHAT THE NEXT BORDERLANDS GAME
WILL BE.
>> YOU ARE LOOKING AT ENGINE
RENDERED IMAGE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF BORDERLANDS 3.
LOOK AT THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT IS PANDORA.
THE ART.
THE STYLE.
THE GOAL WAS TO TRY TO CREATE AN
IMAGE THAT WAS FRESH BUT ALSO
FAMILIAR.
WE WANTED TO LOOK FORWARD AND
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGY IN A WAY THAT
RESPECTS THAT ONE OF A KIND ART
DIRECTION KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE
VIDEO GAME WORLD AS THE
BORDERLANDS ART STYLE.
>> OKAY.
LET'S BE HONEST, THIS ISN'T AN
ACTUAL SCREEN SHOT FROM THE
GAME.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS THE
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] NOW WE
SKIPPED PAST THE LOGOS AND A LOT
OF THE INTRODUCTIONS BECAUSE WE
FELT THAT THE MOST HONEST WAY TO
BRING THE GAME TO YOU TODAY, WAS
TO START FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
SO WITH THAT, LET'S PLAY SOME
BORDERLANDS 3.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YOU MUST BE THE NEW RECRUIT.
I'M A STEWART BOT.
AND YOU CAN CALL ME GENERAL
CLAPTRAP OF THE CRIMSON RAIDERS.
WHAT IS YOUR NAME?
>> AMARA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I'LL PREPARE YOUR TOMBSTONE
JUST IN CASE.
THOSE JERKS THAT TRY TO RUN YOU,
THE CHILDREN OF THE CULT.
ABANDONED CULT THAT FOLLOW THE
CREEPY LEADERS WITH BLIND
DEVOTION WHICH REMINDS ME, IF
YOU ARE GOING TO OBEY MY EVERY
BECKON CALL, YOU WILL NEED AN
ECHO DEVICE.
TRY IT OUT.
I RINSED IT OFF MYSELF.
THE ELKO 3.
SLIGHTLY MORE POWERFUL THAN THE
ECHO 2 AND TWICE AS EXPENSIVE.
BESIDES, THE ECHO 2 HAD A TINY
ISSUE WITH SPONTANEOUS
COMBUSTION.
NOW LISTEN UP, RECRUIT, LILITH
ORDERED US TO TAKE OVER THE
CHILDREN OF THE BULK PROPAGANDA
CENTER.
TRY TO SHOW THOSE KULTI WEIRDOES
THAT NO ONE MESSES WITH THE
CRIMSON RAIDERS.
FOLLOW ME TO GLORY!
>> SO LILITH ORDERED US TO TAKE
OVER THE RECRUITMENT CENTER OF
THE CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
IN THE INTRODUCTION THAT WE
SKIPPED, YOU WOULD LEARN THAT
THE CHILDREN OF THE VAULT IS A
NEW CULT THAT HAS EMERGED ON
PANDORA.
SIREN LILITH AND THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS ARE RECRUITING NEW VAULT
HUNTER, THAT IS YOU, US, AND WE
ARE TO INVESTIGATE THE CHILDREN
OF THE VAULT CULT AND DISCOVER
WHO THEIR MYSTERIOUS LEADERS
ARE.
>> BEFORE WE REEK OUR RIGHTEOUS
VENGEANCE, REGISTER YOUR ECHO AT
THIS CHANGE.
ONCE WE DEFEAT THE CULT, I'LL BE
FAMOUS.
WHEN I AM SIGNING AUTOGRAPHS, I
NEED YOU LOOKING SHARP WHILE
DEFENDING ME FROM MY
FAN/STALKERS.
>> AS HERE, WE ARE PLAYING
AMARA.
A WARRIOR.
AS CLAPTRAP MENTIONED, QUICK
CHANGE, UP TO YOU HOW YOU WANT
YOUR CHARACTER TO LOOK.
YOU CAN CHANGE AMARA AND CHANGE
IT OBVIOUSLY.
LET'S KEEP PLAYING FOR NOW,
GUYS.
>> USER AGREEMENT?
BORING.
DON'T WORRY.
CORPORATIONS HAVE OUR BEST
INTEREST AT HEART.
THE PROPAGANDA CENTER IS THIS
WAY!
LOCK, ENGAGE.
THAT CAN'T BE HAPPENING.
THE ENTIRE MISSION IS RUINED.
THINK CLAPTRAP, YOU ARE GREAT,
POWERFUL AND PEOPLE ALWAYS DO
WHAT YOU TELL THEM TO.
THAT IS IT.
RECRUIT.
GET THAT GATE OPEN.
THIS IS AN ORDER FROM YOUR
SUPERIOR OFFICER.
>> SO OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE GETTING
A GLIMPSE HERE ON HOW WE USE THE
BEGINNING OF THE GAME TO MAKE
SURE THAT PLAYERS ARE UP TO
SPEED HOW FIRST PERSON VIDEO
GAMES WORK.
WE CAN VALIDATE THAT PLAYERS
UNDERSTAND HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND INTERACT WITH
IT.
>> YOU DID IT!
BEST RECRUIT EVER!
DON'T GET COCKY.
>> WE'LL EVEN BE ABLE TO KNOW
HOW A PLAYER HAS LEARNED HOW TO
CROUCH AND HOW TO SLIDE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] YOU HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN JUMP.
AND IF YOU MISS, THAT YOU CAN
MANTLE UP, CLIMB THE HIGHER
LEDGES.
>> THE PROPAGANDA CENTER IS UP
AHEAD.
THEY HAVE BEEN KILLING LEFT AND
RIGHT.
THEY TOTALLY SUCK SKAG BALLS.
I HAVE A FULL PROOF PLAN TO KICK
THEIR [ EXPLETIVE ].
>> WITH MOST GAMES, WE ARE USING
THE BEGIN TO TEACH THE
FUNDAMENTALS AND SETTING THE
TONE OF THE GAME.
RIGHT?
JUST LIKE OUR UNIQUE ART STYLE,
WE WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL RIGHT
AWAY WHAT WE BELIEVE HELPS
BORDERLANDS SPECIAL.
A STYLE OF WRITING THAT IS
RIVERRENCE AND GENUINE.
>> I HID A WEAPONS CASH NEARBY.
STAY QUIET AND FOLLOW MY EVERY
MOVE.
IT IS SEALTH TIME!
[ SINGING ]
PERFECT.
ONCE WE COMPLETE OUR MISSION,
LILITH HAS TO PROMOTE ME TO
SUPER GENERAL.
STAND BACK!
>> SO WE ARE THROWING SETH OUT
THE WINDOW?
>> RELAX, IT IS PANDORA, SUPER
WEIRD IF SOMETHING IS NOT
EXPLODING.
TAKE YOUR GUN, RECRUIT.
YOU WILL NEED IT.
THESE GUNS, LIKE MYSELF, AREN'T
BEHOLDEN TO PRIMARY FUNCTION.
I CAN DANCE.
AND SING.
♪ AND NOW SOME GUNS INCLUDE AN
ALTERNATE SHOOTING MODE  ♪
>> TRY IT OUT!
FOLLOW ME, RECRUIT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IS CLAPTRAP JUST MENTIONED IN
ORDER TO STAY COMPETITIVE, SOME
OF OUR GUN MANUFACTURERS HAVE
ADDED ALTERNATE FIRING MODES.
IF WE LOOK HERE, WE CAN SEE THAT
WE HAVE A PISTOL.
IF WE FIRE REGULARLY, WE FIRE
BULLETS.
BUT IF WE SWITCH OUR ALTERNATE
FIRING MODES, WE FIRE OFF MICRO
MISSILES.
[APPLAUSE] NOW LATER IN THE
GAME, YOU WILL FIND GUNS THAT
CAN SWITCH BETWEEN ICE BULLETS
AND FIRE BULLETS OR YOU MIGHT
FIND GUNS THAT HAVE A CHAIN GUN
ON TOP, WHEN SWITCH FIRING
MODES, SHOOT GRENADES.
IT GETS CRAZY.
PLAYER WHOSE MAXIMIZE ALL FIRE
MODES, TWICE THE NUMBER OF GUNS
AVAILABLE THAN THEY HAD TO START
WITH.
>> WAIT HERE.
I WILL TALK MY WAY IN, BECOME
THEIR KING AND YOU WILL SURPRISE
SLAUGHTER THEM IN COLD BLOOD.
WATCH AND LEARN, RECRUIT.
HELLO!
ANYONE THERE?
>> THE INFLUENCER ON THE
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
WHAT DO YOU WANT BOT?
>> HELLO, BLOOD THIRSTY MANIAC.
IT IS I, CLAPTRAP, SLAYER OF THE
DESTROYER.
SUPER GENERAL OF THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
WE HAVE YOU COMPLETELY
SURROUNDED.
OPEN THE GATES NOW.
PERHAPS I WILL BE MERCIFUL.
>> OH, YEAH, LET ME THINK ABOUT
THAT.
>> THEY MIGHT CALL THEMSELVES
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT BUT STILL
BANDITS.
BANDITS ARE INCREDIBLY STUPID.
>> OKAY.
WE ARE GOING TO SURRENDER.
PLEASE DON'T KILL US.
>> THAT IS WHAT I THOUGHT.
OPEN THE DOORS IMMEDIATELY FOR
YOUR NEW KING.
>> EASY, EASY.
WE ARE COMING OUT.
JUST WAIT RIGHT THERE.
>> HE DID IT.
I DID IT.
ANOTHER VICTORY FOR THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
HEY, I FEEL FUNNY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO ME?
WHOA!
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> SEE THE DEGRADING COVER.
>> LOOKIE WHAT WE GOT HERE!
>> OH, OH!
BORDERLANDS 3 IS RATED M FOR
MATURE, RIGHT?
>> PUT THESE BULLETS INTO THE
BAD GUY, RIGHTED?
>> YOU ARE GOING TO BE MY NEW
TEAM BOT.
I'M GOING TO GET IN YOUR HEAD.
>> WHOA!
REGROUP!
>> I KNOW CLAPTRAP CAN BE A
LITTLE CLAPTRAP BUT HE IS STILL
ONE OF US.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO SAVE
HIM.
I'LL BE THERE SOON.
>> SO LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND
SOME LOOT.
I SAW OVER HERE NEAR THAT DOOR,
I SAW A RED CHEST.
IT LOOKS LIKE A TRUNK OF A CAR.
WHAT DO WE GOT HERE?
WHAT ELSE IS THERE?
OH, THAT IS INTERESTING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WE CAN SEE THAT THIS WEAPON
HAS HIGH ACCURACY, HIGHER
HANDLING, LET'S LOOK AT THE
OTHER ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS WEAPON HAS HIGHER DAMAGE
AND HIGHER RELOAD TIME.
IT IS FINESSE OR BRUTE FORCE IN
THIS CASE.
>> WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
SHOOT FROM THE HIP OR BAD [
EXPLETIVE ] SCOPE?
I THINK THAT YOU GUYS SAID
SCOPE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
TAKE BOTH OF THEM.
WE WILL TRY THE SCOPE AND THEN
WE WILL SWITCH.
THAT IS PRETTY BAD [ EXPLETIVE
].
THESE ARE LIKE LEVEL ONE GUNS,
TOO.
>> OVER HERE!
>> OH!
>> OIL IS FLAMMABLE.
>> THERE IS NO WAY WITH YOUR
DELICATE BODY CAN SURVIVE A
SHOWDOWN.
LOOK AROUND FOR A SHIELD!
>> OKAY.
WE NEED A SHIELD.
THIS IS AN AREA MISSION.
IF WE LOOK AROUND, WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO FIND SOME SOMEWHERE.
NOT IN THE SKAG PILE.
>> DEQUAN, YOU ON THIS?
ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT LOOKS PROMISING.
THERE WE GO.
77.
105, THAT IS BETTER.
TAKE THAT ONE.
>> IT JUST MIGHT KEEP HIM FROM
KILLING YOU IN ONE HIT.
LET'S GET YOU IN THERE RECRUIT.
HEY!
ALL YOUR DUMB FRIENDS ARE DEAD!
I CHALLENGE YOU TO A TRIAL BY
COMBAT!
BUT BECAUSE I'M STUCK WITH THIS,
MY ROYAL SHALL TAKE ISSUE
INSTEAD.
>> COME ON IN.
I HAVEN'T MET MY SACRIFICE QUOTA
FOR THE DAY!
>> SO I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GETTING AHEAD OF ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS COMING NEXT.
THIS IS OUR FIRST MINI BOSS
FIGHT.
DEQUAN, YOU READY?
WE ARE FLYING WITHOUT A NET
HERE.
NO GOD MODE.
SO LET'S DO IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NICE!
>> OH!
[APPLAUSE]
>> MY GOD!
THAT WAS AWESOME.
>> SCORE ONE FOR THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
YOU AND CLAPTRAP SECURE THE
AREA.
I'M ON MY WAY.
>> THIS GAME IS DYNAMIC,
DIFFERENT EVERY TIME THEY PLAY
IT.
THAT WAS THE BEST KILL EVER.
I'M GLAD YOU GOT TO SEE THAT.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> RECRUIT, ARE YOU DEAD?
IF NOT, GET ME DOWN!
THE CONTROLS ARE ON THE SECOND
FLOOR.
>> NOW YOU'LL NOTICE THAT DEQUAN
PICKED UP THE SHOTGUN THAT SHIV
DROPPED.
WE THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT MOMENT OF VICTORY SHOULD
HAVE A SUBSEQUENT REWARD AT THAT
MOMENT.
SO OF COURSE, YOU CAN PICK UP
GEAR RIGHT AWAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, DUDE.
DEQUAN HAS THE SAME AFFLICTION I
HAVE, YOU HAVE TO OPEN EVERY
SINGLE FRICKEN' CHEST.
THIS IS A DEMO.
ALL RIGHT.
IT IS SO TEMPT, THOSE GREEN
LIGHTS.
OH, CLAPTRAP IS NAGGING AT US
ALREADY.
IT IS NOT A BORDERLANDS GAME
UNLESS CLAPTRAP TRUMPS BETWEEN
NEEDY, BOSSY AND PATHETIC.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
IT, I STILL KIND OF LOVE
CLAPTRAP.
LET'S HELP HIM OUT.
THIS BORDERLANDS 3, YOU CAN
REVIVE MPC'S AND MPC'S CAN
REVIVE YOU!
LET'S HELP OUT CLAPTRAP.
>> FOCUS!
WOW!
I DID IT.
I SINGLE HANDILY TAKE ON THE CMV
AND SENT THEM PACKING.
ALL THAT IS LEFT IS SIGNAL
LILITH THAT THE MISSION IS
COMPLETE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> LILITH, I CAN SAFELY REPORT
THAT OPERATION IS A COMPLETE
SUCCESS.
I DID IT ALL BY MYSELF.
>> I'LL BET.
WELL, THE CULT HAS DESTROYED
EVERY OTHER CRIMSON RAIDER
STRONGHOLD.
THIS WILL HAVE TO DO FOR NOW.
SO WHAT'S YOUR NAME, KILLER?
>> I AM AMARA.
NICE TATTOO SIREN SISTER.
YOU MUST BE THE VOICE IN MY
HEAD.
>> YEAH, ABOUT THAT, NOT THE
WEIRDEST THING YOU WILL SEE ON
PANDORA.
BUT SERIOUSLY, THANKS FOR
ANSWERING HI CALL.
WE MIGHT NOT HAVE THE NUMBERS
BUT WITH A BAD [ EXPLETIVE ]
LIKE YOU, WE HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE.
WELCOME TO THE CRIMSON RAIDERS.
>> HEY, DO YOU HEAR BLOOD
THIRSTY SCREAMING?
>> MORE COV.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT, RECRUIT.
>> IT IS THE FIRE HAWK!
>> WATCH IT!
>> YOU'RE ON THE WRONG TEAM [
EXPLETIVE ].
>> S